Oh,
I have a unique perspective.
My perspective is less and
less inclined to pursue it in,
in the idea that it's a fight and more
to be able to pursue reason and to have
everybody communicate with each other.
Because I think part of what the fuck
is wrong with all of us today is that
people are so willing to take sides,
so willing to join teams and so willing
to fight about shit that they really
don't have
fight about trying to beat me. I
wanted to say this. I'm a sad cause.
It's just so powerful.
I don't dislike Donald Trump and I
think he's done some good things.
I'm trying to do piece and trying
to get jobs back to America,
but I hate Donald Trump
because I got behind him was,
I knew Hillary was bad and then he
became my identity. He is not a bad guy,
but the truth is I hate him more than
Hillary Clinton because he's who I am now
and whatever he does is who I am from
North America and freedom and everything
else.
And I'm not throwing him under the bus
to get George Soros on my back though.
They're already asked me for the,
for the reasons I'm not with them.
I'm not against even Trump,
but I get in a fight like this that's so
dumbed down that then no matter what I
do, they take my radical illness,
my weirdness to hurt Trump.
But then all it does is like
radioactively attack me. I don't,
I don't know how to describe it,
but it's like I,
it's like Trump is breaking my legs every
day and it's not like I'm not willing
to go through the pain except a lot of
what he says I don't agree with and he's
not my identity.
Shani hooks not mine.
Your own personal perspective, and I
appreciate that, that he's not your dad.
I don't know how many people actually
think he said he's your identity,
but I think that what we're getting
at that's important is that we don't,
no, when they're shooting at me,
they're going to Trump. I'm sure.
I'm sure there's a lot at all.
Mine's the shooting at Joe.
It's that I'm not Donald Trump.
I understand that from you,
but what I'm talking about is
just the human race in general.
If we could just do one thing,
be reasonable,
just be reasonable and understand that
emotions cloud judgment and that when
people start screaming and yelling at
each other and you take one side and
you're the left and this guy takes
another side and he's the right and you're
going back and forth to mindless,
it's nonsense and you don't ever get
anything solved and you never get to
understand how that other person thinks
and feels and we're constantly trying to
mock people.
And what you were talking about about
the bill Maher thing about him cracking a
joke and I dismissed it as a
joke because it was a joke.
He's talking about how the red states
wish they were the blue states and all
that shit. That's that's exactly the
type of thing we're talking about though,
that that,
that that US versus them that me versus
like you're generalizing for entire
swaths of the country is if there was,
I feel bad every time I
say California is lost.
This is a beautiful state
and a lot of great people.